all right now we're ready to learn how
to do circuit analysis this is what
we've been shooting for as we've learned
our fundamental laws and the fundamental
laws are Ohm's law and Kirchhoff's laws
which we learned with Kirchhoff's
current law and Kirchhoff's voltage law
this says that the sum of all the
currents going into a node adds up to
zero and the voltage law says the sum of
the voltages going around a loop adds up
to zero and the other thing we learned
was the sign convention so we had a
passive sign convention which was if I
label the voltage like that then I label
the current flowing into the positive
end the positive end and the current go
together so these are the tools that we
have for analyzing a circuit and I've
drawn a circuit here so what we see is
we have a voltage source we'll call that
V s and it will give it a value of 15
volts we have a resistor r1 that has a
value we'll give that a value of 4 K
ohms and another resistor r2 is sitting
right here and we'll give it a value of
2 K ohms 2000 ohms and finally there's a
current source sitting over here and it
has a value of 3 milliamps flowing
downwards so the point of circuit
analysis means what we want to do is we
want to find all the currents and all
the voltages in this circuit using our
fundamental laws so let's identify first
let's identify the nodes in the circuit
we'll give them we'll give them letter
names we'll call this node a and that's
the junction between R 1 and V s we'll
give this one a name this is a node
that's distributed all three of these
components joined right about here we'll
call that node B and that's one of the
nodes
and down at the bottom here there's the
third node which is this distributed
node here it connects the voltage source
the resistor and the current source and
this is all we'll call that node see now
we could also label some voltages on
here we'll label the label the voltages
we'll do that in orange okay we'll call
this v1 and we'll give it a plus sign
here and a minus sign here and that's
the voltage across R 1 will give our two
a name
we'll get the voltage here we'll call
this plus minus v2 that's the voltage
across r2 it's also the voltage across
the current source B it's the voltage
between node B and node C and now let's
label the currents let's label the
currents in this circuit we have a
current coming through r1 we'll call
that I one there's another current going
through r2 and we'll call that I two
there's a current going here through is
and we actually already know that we'll
just call that is and that's all the
currents that's all the unknown currents
in our circuit if we if we stare at this
we're not going to be able to tell on
just inspecting this what's going on we
have to come up with some solution
technique and we're going to solve this
by what's called application of the
fundamental laws and here's our laws
over here and the whole technique is
based on solving simultaneous
equations
that's the skill of circuit analysis
circuit analysis means setting up and
solving simultaneous equations so let's
write down some things we know about the
circuit and first thing we're going to
apply is we'll apply Ohm's law to the
two resistors so we can say V 1 equals I
1 times R 1 and we can say that V 2
equals I 2 times R 2 all right that's
not a bad start we have two equations
how many unknowns do we have I 2 and V 2
are unknown I 1 and R 1 are unknowns so
we have four unknowns and we have two
equations so we're we're halfway there
and now we need to come up with some
more equations and I'm just going to
stare at the circuit and what I'm going
to do is I'm going to apply KVL around
this loop here that's going to be my KVL
loop and after we get that equation what
we're going to do is we're going to
write KCl we're going to write the
current law at node B that's the two
equations we're going to develop here so
let's do KVL let's start let's start in
this node at this corner of the circuit
and go around clockwise around and what
we see first is a voltage rise plus plus
vs
next I see a voltage drop so it's minus
v1 going around this way minus v1 at
this point now I'm going to go through
our two and I see a voltage drop of v2
minus v2 equals zero that's kerkoff's
voltage law around this loop one rise
two drops one rise two drops now we're
going to move up here and do kirchoff's
current law at this node right here so
let me draw a few more arrows
this is i1 it comes right through that
resistor and this is I s so kirchoff's
current law let's count the currents
going into node b current going into
node b is i1 currents going out we'll
set that equal to the sum of the
currents going out of node B so that's
equal to i2 plus is
so look and now I have my four equations
here's my four simultaneous equations
and this is what we have to solve so let
me move the screen up and we'll we'll
start doing that let's do a double check
we had four unknowns V 1 I 1 V 2 I 2
here's V 1 and V 2 and here's I 1 and I
2 and I have four equations so we ought
to be able to do this